we got a whole bunch of stuff to talk
about price went down it went up it went
down it went up fomc etc uh maybe first
let's talk about your reaction to uh
interest rates not moving yesterday i
know you were pretty bullish on it being
a buy the news type event which it seems
to have been yeah you know i just think
um you know i texted you this in the
last couple days i i just thought that
the market
had been de-risking over the last couple
weeks right and so whenever you have
some kind of known event like this um
you know generally people
the framework i'm going to talk about
people generally applied to like uh buy
the buy the room or sell the news right
where you have you know kind of the
insider's getting in first information
comes out you know the kind of works its
way down the informational you know
totem pole or human centipede of
information by the time it gets to the
end when the event comes there's no new
buyers because everyone's already buying
in anticipation of this event right and
so um my kind of thesis over the last
few days and you know this kind of why i
texted you is like
what i what i was thinking was kind of
this reverse
in the sense of you know you're selling
the room or buying the news because
everyone's already de-risking and then
by the time you get to the event right
that everyone's saying is going to be
bearish because they've all risked off
heading into it
who are going to be the sellers left and
i think that we kind of saw that
yesterday where um you know the fed was
slightly more you know
hawkish than i kind of expected them to
be but you know i i think um you know
the only the only real sellers that
would have stepped in yesterday are
people that um you know had had been
expecting the fed not to raise rates um
and and somehow that would affect their
crypto you know thesis
and so you know yesterday i wasn't
really surprised to see that kind of be
this this by the you know by the news
event um if you will um
and so yeah i mean i i wasn't you know
all too surprised at all by the reaction
that we got um you know as well
um you know leading up to that we also
saw a couple other kind of telltale
signs but just from like a fundamental
perspective you know i think um
just you know doing some thinking as to
like you know sometimes you just it's as
simple as thinking like okay who are
going to be the buyers or sellers for
this event um and so conversely like you
know the opposite of this would have
been like
you know the uh the the coinbase you
know which was you know the absolute in
the coinbase ipo which was the absolute
you know pico top on april 14th so for
some of these events um you know
sometimes it's not entirely obvious you
know sometimes um sometimes you'll say
okay i know there's going to be some
kind of reaction uh but not you know
sure exactly you know where it's going
to break for example like i think
coinbase was a better example in that
case where it wasn't so clear but um you
know once we started to see the market
break a certain direction then you know
you would have um you know then become
cautious but you know this during this
specific event i think it was pretty
clear that you know just thinking about
who where the sellers can be left it's
really hard to you know think that you
know the majority of those who are going
to do risk hadn't already done so
all right one of the things that i saw
that you pulled up we've got a couple of
charts here uh that i think is
absolutely fascinating is that even
though the price has been drawing down
we've got this purpose bitcoin etf uh it
looks like people are still putting
assets into this thing so what is this
showing us
right we're just looking at the holdings
of uh the purpose bitcoin etf which is a
spot etf in canada
and what we've seen over the last two
weeks is their holdings have actually um
and by the way you know i haven't done
the newsletter this week so i might mess
up some numbers here because i'm not
reading off the off my newsletter but i
think they've added about 240 million
dollars of btc in the last two weeks uh
during this drawdown which is anything
that's going to significantly move the
market right but um you know at the same
time it it you know it's it's just more
of a um
you know a sign to see that there is
still hunger from you know people
looking to to you know buy bitcoin and
um you know likely uh you know
institutional or kind of traditional
investors that are going to buy through
an etf versus just you know take custody
of their bitcoin so
you know i just think that's a kind of a
promising sign in terms of looking at
you know like institutional flows if you
will um you know
we i think in total now they hold like
one and a half billion dollars of btc um
and you know this is just uh something
for gary gensler to look at and see you
know there's definitely an appetite for
you know spot pick one etf
all right then when we start to look at
the supply shock ratios we've been
talking about these for months and
months and months and months now uh back
in june and july a lot of people uh will
remember that you explicitly highlighted
this idea of a bullish divergence you've
got it labeled on this chart here uh
when you look at this is it happening
again like how do you look at this and
what is this telling us
totally so um you know first of all just
before we get into the specific chart
you know the way i'm the way i'm looking
at um and this is kind of evolved is the
way i see this is like on chain is macro
right so we have that kind of giving you
the underlying like broader current of
the market and then we can look at
things like you know order books or
derivatives data which is extremely
important on the shorter term time
frames and then price action is kind of
our confirmation of that
so with that being said right now we
have a bullish divergence between
the liquid supply shock ratio and price
which means that we're seeing supply
moving to
long-term investors or entities that
have very low spending history meaning
they take in and hold at least three out
of every four coins that they take in
and this is this is very different to
what we saw over may or or in may i
should say um in may you saw this
decline as we kind of had this relief
bounce if you will
and at the time you know if you had this
metric you definitely would have wanted
to be cautious right because you're
seeing supply moving from entities that
were previously
strong hands to now becoming weakened so
supply moving from entities who take in
and hold most of their coins that are
now becoming those weak handed entities
or liquid or highly liquid entities
and so there's a kind of a key
difference between that and kind of the
underlying structure of what's going on
in the market right now you don't have
fundamental investors that are currently
turning into
weak hands this was also reflected in um
and this is kind of a good segue to the
chart i sent it's uh net unreal i'm
sorry net realized profit loss
and so
on kind of a similar note what you'll
see here is that currently uh investors
are realizing profits i mean i'm sorry
realizing losses more than profits which
just means that you have supply that was
previously bought overhead
is now being sold you know at these
price levels so you know people that
essentially bought the top are now
capitulating down here
versus you know fundamental investors
that bought in you know a long time ago
that are now deciding that this is some
kind of fair value for them to sell
their btc
you have more so it's kind of
capitulation from top buyers i mean that
especially happened uh last week as you
can see that big big spike down and
we've kind of been progressively making
you know higher lows in that meaning
that uh the kind of the amount of uh
realized losses is you know subsiding i
mean you know meaning that the kind of
capitulation is slowing um and so that
that's kind of a ties into the previous
chart i looked at meaning and what i'm
just trying to say out of all this is
that
the sellers that we've had recently so
initially we had this large drawdown
right because we had all these over
leveraged longs um and then you know
recently we've just had people kind of
capitulating and that's been getting
absorbed by long-term investors and
we're just kind of in this range right
for the past two weeks we've just talked
about you know last week i said i'm a
crab market maximalist right
we're just you know we're just chilling
in this range uh and you know until
until we have some kind of clear break
in in my opinion that's defined as you
know getting above and holding 53k um or
below 40k for the very scenario um you
know until we break either of those kind
of uh you know
you know invalidation points um you know
i think we're still just ranging right
and and so like it's really easy to get
you know chopped up in these ranges you
know i see like twitter sentiment it's
like we get to the top of the range and
everyone thinks we're going to the moon
we get to the bottom and everyone's
saying we're going to zero
this like the same thing that happened
over summer right like every time we got
down like 30k everyone's like oh my god
you know 20k you know this is it or
we're going to zero uh every time we got
to the top of the range especially when
they had like with that one move up to
like 40k everyone got like insanely
bullish
um you know i think i think it's really
important to just have these like kind
of key
uh you know invalidation points that
kind of say okay yeah we're you know
we've either you know broke into the
upside or downside of the range um and
to me that's that's 53k which we'll get
into in a second um as well as 40 40k to
the downside i think like you definitely
don't want to lose um 40k for the bulls
i think uh though you know that would i
you know i've been cautious since since
we you know had all the derivatives
piled up and especially after we broke
below 53 because i said that was kind of
like my my you know uptrend uh kind of
cut off for for bitcoin um but you know
definitely you know if we if we broke 40
40k that you know be pretty bearish
but you know to say that we've gotten
back out of this range uh which has been
kind of caught between you know 42 and
52k
i'd be looking for a break and hold
above 53 which we can talk about in a
second as to a couple different reasons
why i think that's the case okay now
let's talk about the future perpetual
funding rate across all of the different
exchanges uh this is always fascinating
to me but i think you understand it way
better than i do so what is this showing
us
right um so the the purpose based on i'm
sorry the funding rate is based on the
premium between the per price and the
spot index price
and so essentially you're just looking
at you know are our uh you know perps
more aggressive or um or spot or spot
more aggressive um and so what we see is
that whenever whenever we have some kind
of major capitulation event or like
liquidation event we generally kind of
carve out this uh you know kind of
regime is what i've kind of called it
of mixed and mixed uh to negative
funding meaning that you know traders
are essentially in disbelief um so you
saw this um after march 2020 we were
just predominantly just straight up
negative funding
another good example would be september
of last year after september of last
year we kind of carved out this mixed
regime of funding you know kind of
leaning negative before that big october
rally that we had which is essentially a
disbelief rally um going off of what
funding was saying because you know by
seeing mixed funding it's you know just
that literally just means that you know
traders are uncertain right
and then another example would be over
the summer we had mixed to leaning
negative funding
and so you know seeing seeing funding
kind of flip negative as well as just
maintaining this kind of muted level
that's a good sign for bulls um you know
that's that's kind of our what what our
base case has been since this
kind of initial liquidation event um you
know two weeks ago we said what we want
to see for the bulls is seeing this kind
of range
meanwhile you know or consolidation
whatever you want to call it while kind
of carving out this regime of mixed to
negative funding and that's kind of what
we've seen um you know over the last
over the last two weeks or so uh we saw
funding flipped negative yesterday uh
leading into the kind of uh you know
faulty news so
um yeah that what i'm looking for
funding is just to continue to just
carve out this regime of mixed to
negative as long as continue to range
all right and then we've got the
on-chain cost basis here which i think
is probably uh driving some of your kind
of price levels that you're talking
about earlier so explain what on-chain
cost basis is and then why you're so
fixated on the numbers that you're
talking about with 53 40 et cetera
right so we're just looking at the
average price of which investors bought
in on chain
um for like technical traders you know
what i would say is the way you think of
this is like a v-wap so volume weighted
average price
and so this this price level has been
really important if we zoom out you'll
see this is served as support for the
you know 2017 bull market um once we
broke below you know we flipped bearish
and then we kind of had these failed
underside re-tests the whole way down
into the bottom of the bear in 2018 once
we got back above this we you know came
back off of the lows and in the bottom
of the bear
we broke below this about two weeks ago
went below 53k and what i said was until
we reclaim this i maintain you know kind
of this cautious stance and i still do
so um that sits right around 53k um that
also aligns with kind of technical this
kind of nice technical level as well as
the one trillion dollar market cap
threshold
and so this is this is why i keep saying
53k 53k i'm sure people are like tired
of hearing that um you know that that's
kind of where i'm getting that number
from so you know once once we get back
above that um i'll happily you know load
on load on btc um and just to be clear
you know i have i have a you know dca
that i'm regularly dc and so i also have
a trading portfolio so when i'm talking
about this i'm talking about my trading
portfolio um you know if we get back
above 53 i'd love to just happily pile
back in but until then i kind of
maintained um you know caution in that
sense uh so i would i would look to
either buy the 53k um you know break
or i would look to kind of uh you know
buy if we retest that that wick down
being a below call it you know between
42 to 45k with invalidation at 40k
so those are kind of the two areas that
i'm kind of looking to do business if
you will
um you know but but you know for the
bulls you you want to see 53k get
reclaimed but in terms of like where i
would buy
yeah it would either be you know
reclaiming that that level or you know
looking for some kind of uh you know uh
you know buy below below this you know
uh
you know if we swing the wick you know
down to
42 45k
and then invalidation would be at 40k
got it joe what questions you got well
what's going on man good to see you
again um so my question would just be
around like you personally how do you
look at the the more high-level macro
stuff right so we got news yesterday
that they're signaling three rate hikes
for 2022. how does this impact your view
from the on-chain side
right um so yeah i mean
being like a bitcoin analyst i think it
you know it's definitely something you
need to keep in mind but at the same
time like i'm not gonna sit here and
like pretend that i'm like this expert
macro analyst right and so like i think
it's it's almost difficult enough
already to keep up with the bitcoin
market let alone like predict you know
what's going to go on with macro and so
the way i kind of look at this is like
if if investor behaviors change then
you'll see that through
price and on chain data
and so those are kind of the two like
true tellers because you know obviously
like
macro included in this like there's a
lot of variables right and so
to kind of just like
get you know the signal of all of that
information you know in in uh in a
concise way you can look at what's the
behavior of the investors on chain and
you know the purest version of that is
just looking at what the price action is
telling you because that's the
aggregated opinion of all market
participants about all information given
right
and so yeah i mean i don't really i
don't really like
like try to read too much into what's
going on with the fed you know i have
people much smarter than me that i
listen to in that regard
um but yeah i mean in terms of like what
people or what the market thinks about
it i just watch what happens you know
with price and and what happens in the
launching data to kind of gauge what
people are making of that because you
know that that's like literally telling
you the reaction of people to all the
information at hand so yep gotcha man
thanks john will so my question is
it's not funny my question is around
kind of the having cycles and where you
think we are so we obviously had a
having in 2020 we're going to have
another one on 2024 but we went up and
up in the spring down in the summer up
in the fall looks like we're kind of
consolidating what people consider a
bull market what are your thoughts
around the having in like the price of
bitcoin right now
yeah i don't i mean i think there's a
correlation but i don't really think it
matters to be honest um and the
reasoning is because
the having well a like having the uh
kind of the supply shock if you will
that it has on the market is completely
diminished from like the first one so
like you know the first having in 2013
is pretty significant given the issuance
versus the amount of circulating supply
but at this point the next having will
pretty much just you know be relevant in
terms of uh you know the the magnitude
of it um and then second of all the
other reason i'm kind of talking about
like veering from these four year cycles
is just the type of market participant
that we have
um you know i think i think these are
much more sophisticated market
participants um and not to say that we
won't have you know 50 to 80 drawdowns
uh i just i just kind of lean away from
this very clean you know looking you
know four-year logarithmic kind of we
cup up you know have a parabolic blow
off top come back down and accept this
you know
just traditional whenever you look at
like logarithmic regression charts for
bitcoin i think i think uh
too many people and this is like my pin
tweet is like too many people have been
trying to you know project the past on
to the future rather than think like
what does the future look like
and so by no means am i saying that
we're going to go up forever at all i
mean obviously like i've been actually
kind of like standing away from that um
but you know when someone talks about
like what is a super cycle right a super
cycle would be
you know kind of having these rounded
tops and bottoms moving forward uh
without any kind of major you know blah
top so like my invalidation for my idea
here would be if we do have a blow off
top like if we have a blow off top i
would i would very much expect that we
have some kind of you know prolonged
bear market but until we have you know
some kind of parabolic blow off top i
think we'll continue to kind of see
these these rounded tops and bottoms
moving forward and that's just a
reflection of the type of like market
participant that we have now is it fair
to say the having in 2013 wasn't almost
priced in because it was so significant
on the amount of bitcoin that got cut in
half and then people are starting to
realize that it is a little bit or no
yeah yeah i mean i think that's the case
back in 2013 um but by now you know i i
if anything it's just like a a
psychological thing that people say like
oh yeah well whenever this happens this
happens right rather than like the the
amount of supply getting cut in half
actually having like a material effect
on you know the supply dividend dynamics
in the market um with that being said
though i don't think that means that you
know as soon as the having happens
people say like oh well every time
there's a having price goes up you know
if if if you think that's the case then
it just gets front ramp right like you
know the type of investors we have now
in the market are really smart so you
know they're just going to say oh well
if this happens every time that there's
a having then we'll just front run that
so you know i i don't really i'm not
like paying too much attention to the
the having moving forward um you know i
just think we're kind of
um
i'm not saying like oh this time is
different per se i just think like we
have a different type of market
participant and so the market structure
is going to change and it won't just be
a repetitive you know four year cycle i
think i just think kind of that's like
intellectually lazy and i think like
that's just you know it would be very
nice for crypto natives because then
they could just you know
buy in the bear and then just sell off
in the bowl and then just chill until
the next you know bulmar you know i i
just don't think that's that's really
going to help that's going to be how it
goes you know i think also like talking
to some people who are um you know
obviously my kids so like i'm not i
don't talk to like a bunch of
institutions but talking to people who
do
um you know like i i don't think you're
gonna see like capital you know coming
into the space slow down and also you
know it takes time
so like over the last year or so if you
had you know different institutions that
are looking to allocate you know it
takes them you know sometimes like a
year plus or two years plus to you know
be able to
to you know get to the point of making
the decision that they want to start
allocating to being able to actually
allocate especially for some of these
like public companies
um they're like big you know like
bureaucratic you know institutions so
you know i just think like over time
you're going to see the market structure
change
in my base case for what that will look
like it's just that we have these
rounded tops and bottoms and then the
invalidation for that is if we do some
kind of like parabolic blow off top
gotcha will before we let you go
i know that you know that you're young
but you're one of the most informed
hardest working hungriest people in this
entire industry and rather than you
thinking about it from the sense of hey
i don't talk to that many institutions
you should think about they should have
to pay me a hundred thousand dollars an
hour to talk to me because i got the
goods that they need
right that's why you ain't talking to
him because they can't afford you that's
why the truth is facts
thanks mom
all right man listen
where are we on the follower account how
how is that going
i think we're i don't know we're uh
we're we're coming in here close
450 close to 500.
i told you boys everyone watching this
show go fall will he's got 20 26 000
more followers to go and we got 14 days
well that's less than 2 000 a day if my
public math is right you could do this
man come on will do you think uh this is
kind of a random question but do you
think that most of these financial
institutions whether it's uh you know
hedge funds private equity funds you
know people that are more focused on
public equities or whatever do you think
that they'll have on-chain analytics
experts like hire them in the future
yeah like okay so the way i think of on
chain is like
right now we're looking at uh kind of
like these these in like market signals
or like investment signals right and
we're trying to like make predictions of
saying like
what are the behaviors that you know
market participants have partaken
uh you know previously whenever the
market's in a state of exuberance versus
like this depressed state and then
looking for these kind of
rough zones of saying like the mark
bitcoin is you know under overvalued and
so where i think that kind of evolves
over time is like if we're all right and
bitcoin becomes you know the money of
the world right and everything's valued
in sats and we're you know
the whole world is using bitcoin and
dollars no longer exist or you know
whatever kind of extreme of that concept
that you stand with um you know bitcoin
as it grows will the on-chain data will
shift from being more like market
related in terms of like trying to make
investment decisions more so to like
economic data in my opinion yeah so like
then it'll shift to
you know we're looking at what's going
on with you know unchained investors and
of course like all these metrics we have
like it's still very like early innings
you know it's like in my opinion it's
still like the you know third or fourth
inning in terms of like you know the
progression of launching data and where
it's going to get to go i think we may
be in the first inning
right like i still think it's super
early
you're more bullish to me but yeah like
uh i think uh yeah i think like over
time it'll definitely transition to
you're more so just going to be
analyzing this economy that's built on
bitcoin right versus versus like trying
to trying to predict you know if if the
market's going to go up over the next
couple months or not and so like that's
why
that's that's why i'm really in the
space is like
yes i think now you can kind of get an
edge in the market especially pairing it
with other things and not just looking
solely at on chain data but you know it
helps you kind of build this more
balanced view of everything going on the
market but over time i do think like
on-chain analysts will almost become the
like economists of this you know new
bitcoin-centric uh you know economy that
we're in so
that's kind of like my mental framework
for me you're a legend my friend we
appreciate you have fun tomorrow and
we'll pick this up again uh next week
we'll figure out some time around
christmas
thanks man yeah i'll be i'll be taking
it easy in the mountains tomorrow so
enjoy hey willy mountain all right see
you buddy
all right cheers guys